ce dimanche 19 mars l'ambiance était au
rendez-vous au Dôme de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye pour la première
fois depuis 2019 l'Île-de-France a
accueilli un grand meeting de natation
le Giant open c'est un très grand
honneur parce que c'est la plus grande
compétition de natation en France on est
à quelques centaines de jours du début
des Jeux Olympiques et donc pour nous
qui sommes terre de vœux centre de
préparation des Jeux Olympiques c'est un
peu ce point de départ olympique donc on
est ravis évidemment d'accueillir le
monde de la natation à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye je suis fier de
pouvoir promouvoir cet événement c'est
le premier en la matière le Giant open
ici à Saint-Germain-en-Laye c'est on
espère le premier d'une longue édition
parce que à l'époque on avait d'autres
formats de compétition internationaux
les tribunes étaient remplies en famille
ou entre amis les supporters sont venus
nombreux ils étaient 600 ce dimanche
vous voulez voir tous les nageurs que
j'aimais et comme je suis nageur je
voulais peut-être essayer d'améliorer ma
technique en fonction de comment il nage
parce qu'on habite pas loin de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye c'était l'occasion
de pouvoir voir des athlètes qu'on verra
peut-être pas aux JO ce nouveau format
de compétition a d'ailleurs été très
bien accueilli par les nageurs notamment
les deux têtes d'affiches Maxime
Grousset ce n'est au calédonien qui a
remporté le 100 mètres nage libre en 48
50 ou encore charlotte Bonnet nouvelle
record de woman sur le 100 mètres brasse
une super ambiance là pour ma finale
tout le monde m'a super bien encouragé
je l'ai senti c'est la première fois que
je venais ici à Saint-Germain donc très
beau complexe bien pour accueillir des
des meetings comme celui-ci et vraiment
une très très bonne ambiance beaucoup de
publics qui nous encourage et qui sont à
faire nous en équipe de France donc ça
fait plaisir le Giant Open est comme un
avant-goût pour la ville de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye qui a été élu
centre de préparation pour les Jeux
Olympiques de Paris 2024